so what happens when galaxies collide
when these two big black holes
collide is that
is
well um what would happen is that uh
well and i should say that um this is
going to happen near us one day but not
for four billion years because the
andromeda galaxy which is the biggest
galaxy
near to us which is about
three million light years away which is
a big disc galaxy with the black holes
is hub rather like our milky way
and that's
in
falling towards us because they're both
in a common gravitational potential well
and um
that will collide with our galaxy in
about four billion years but it'll be
it'll be
maybe it'll be less a collision and more
of a dance because it'll be like a
swirling situation
but eventually there'll be to be a
merger they'll go through each other and
then merge in fact uh um the nice movies
to be made of this you know computer
simulations yes and it'll go through um
and um
and then um
there's a black hole in the sense of
andromeda and our galaxy and the galax
the black holes will uh
settle towards the center yes
then they will orbit around each other
very fast and then they will eventually
merge
and that'll produce a big burst of
gravitational waves
um a very big burst that an alien
civilization with a lego-like detector
will be able to detect yes well in fact
we'll but we can detect these with them
they're lower frequencies than the
ways that are being detected by ligo so
there's a
space interferometer which can detect
these they're about it's about one cycle
per hour
rather than about a hundred cycles per
second yes it's the ones that detect it
um but
that that would happen but um uh
thinking back to what will happen in
four billion years to uh any of our
descendants they'll be okay because the
um
the the two disc galaxies were merged
it'll end up as a sort of amorphous
elliptical galaxy
but um the stars won't be much closer
together they are now
it'll it'll still be
just twice as many stars in the
structure almost as big and so um
the chance of
another star colliding with our sun
would still be very small and yeah
because there's actually a lot of space
between indeed stars and planets yes the
chance of a star getting close enough to
affect our solar system's orbit is small
and it won't change that very much so
that we could be reassured a heck of a
starry sky though
what would that look well it won't make
much difference even that actually it'll
just be um
wouldn't that look kind of beautiful
when you're swirling or is oh because
it's scrolling so slowly yeah
but they're far away so we just re-twice
as many stars in the sky yeah and but
the pattern changes
yeah the pattern will change a bit and
uh there won't be the milky way because
the milky way
across the sky is because we are looking
in the disk of our galaxy and uh you
lose that and because the um the disk
will be so disrupted
and uh it will be also the spherical
distribution and of course many
characters are like that um and that's
probably because they have been through
mergers of this kind
you